now that we have a basic understanding
of what a ratio is let's see if we can
tackle some more advanced problems so I
have a classroom it's got 55 students in
it 55 students and I also know that the
ratio of boys to girls
the ratio of I'll write it this way boys
to girls is 4 to 7 what I want to know
is how many girls do I need to add so
how many girls need to add or do I need
to add do I need to add for the ratio
for the ratio to become to become 1 to 2
1 to 2 and this is the ratio of boys to
girls I'm not switching the ratio on you
so right now for every four boys I have
seven girls I want to add some girls so
that the ratio becomes for every boy I
have two girls so how can we do this
what is going back to the basic ratio
video the first thing we can do we know
the total number of students and we know
the ratio so maybe it'll help us to
figure out the number of boys and girls
we have right now so our current ratio
is four to seven so boys boys to girls
right now is equal to four to seven that
means what does that mean that means for
every if you add up these two if for
every for every 11 students for every 11
students there are what there are four
boys and seven girls there are four boys
four boys and seven girls and seven
girls that's what this ratio tells us
you give me eleven students of this well
for every you could you could split this
classroom into a bunch of groups and for
every group of eleven you're gonna have
four
and seven girls that's all that tells me
for every 11 students for boys and seven
girls if you split them I guess every
group has the same number of boys and
girls now how many groups of eleven
students there are so there are 55
students we have 55 students total and
we're breaking them into groups of
eleven and where every group will have
the same number of boys and girls so we
have 11 groups 11 sorry we have we
divide by 11 students per group students
per group so how many groups of 11
students do we have that means we have
five groups of 11 students 5 groups of
11 students and we've done this drill
before every group has 4 boys and it has
seven girls so we have five groups five
groups each one has four boys that means
we have five times four which is equal
to 20 boys and we have five times seven
we have five groups five times seven
each group has seven girls of girls so
that's equal to 35 girls and the numbers
add up 20 plus 35 is 55 and 20 to 35 20
to 35 is equal to 4 to 7 so it all works
out so that's what we have right now now
we're going to add girls to the
classroom to change the ratio so let's
do this
so right now we have we have 20 boys we
have 20 boys and we have 35 girls we
just figured we just figured that out
and I'm going to add some girls to the
classroom so I'm going to add some girls
to the classroom and my new ratio after
I add these G girls to the classroom my
new ratio is going to be 1 to 2 1 to 2
so I just have an equation I have one
unknown I could just solve for it you
can almost do this one in your head 20
is 2 what 1 is 2 2 as 20 as to what you
could say Oh 20 is
the one is half of 220 is half of 40 so
you could say oh this must be 40 so G
would be equal to 5 that's how you would
solve it in your head if you want to do
it algebraically you could cross
multiply so you get 35 plus G times 1 so
you get 35 plus G is equal to 2 times 20
is equal to 40 which is essentially what
we did in our head we said hey this
thing has to be equal to 40 so if you
subtract 35 from both sides you get G is
equal to 5 so if you add five girls to
your classroom you're going to have 40
girls so then you would have 40 girls
and you have 20 boys and your ratio is
20 to 40 which is 2 to 4 which is the
same thing as 1 to 2 and we've done our
problem